Welcome back.
President Biden
is calling out
Elon Musk saying the billionaire
bought a social media platform
that, quote, spews lies across the world.
And, quote,
The president's remarks
follow news
that Twitter
laid off thousands of employees,
including 15% of its trust
and safety workforce.
Just a week after
it was acquired by Musk.
CNN tech reporter Brian Fung
is following the story for us.
So, Brian, good to see you.
Let's talk about these massive cuts.
I mean,
and they come just days
before the midterms.
In fact, civil rights groups
say it could
jeopardize the platform's ability
to safeguard the democratic process.
Is Twitter
Is there anybody left at Twitter
to even respond to the critics?
Well, Fred, Twitter is saying
that it's still committed
to protecting the election
and that none of its content moderation
policies have changed.
But as you pointed out,
civil rights groups
and leaders are saying that
even though Twitter
may still have
these policies on the books,
the layoffs could make it harder for them
to enforce the policies
that it does have.
Meanwhile, you have major advertisers
pulling out of
spending on Twitter advertising,
and that's caused sharp declines
in revenue at Twitter,
according to Elon Musk.
And, you know,
to shore up
revenue, Musk
has this kind of harebrained plan to
charge people for verification,
to have that little blue
checkmark next to their accounts,
which some experts have said
could have unintended consequences
if it's rolled out
in the post-election period
or even before the election, potentially
without proper testing.
You could potentially see, for example,
you know,
some people
paying to have that blue checkmark
and then changing their names
to impersonate official accounts or
or try to spread misinformation
under a verified account.
And how would the company respond to that
with a smaller workforce?
It's unclear.
Twitter, of course,
laid off
15% of its
trust and safety team,
but 50%
of its overall workforce
amounting to about
3700 people across the overall company.
All of this, of course, coming
just days before the election,
injecting further uncertainty
into an already chaotic situation Fred.
And Brian,
I think a lot of us
have been reading
all about what a lot of former
Twitter employees have been saying.
But now what about the former CEO?
How, you know,
what kind of reaction
is coming from the former CEO?
Yes.
Well, Jack Dorsey,
the former CEO of Twitter,
just tweeted about a half hour ago
Let me read what he said.
He said, Folks at Twitter, past
and present are strong and resilient.
They will always find a way,
no matter how difficult the moment.
I realize many are angry with me.
I own the responsibility for
why everyone is in this situation.
I grew the company size too quickly.
I apologize for that.
Very interesting tweet
from from Jack Dorsey's
taking accountability or
responsibility for having
grown the company
too large
and thus putting the company
in a position
where layoffs may have been necessary.
But not really addressing
some of the other
election security or election
integrity questions
that are swirling around Twitter
at this time.
That's a very sensitive time, Fred.
Yeah, a remarkable sequence of events.
Brian Fong, thanks so much.